[موسيقى]
تناول طعام راقٍ ، عليك أن تفعل شيئًا
مختلفًا ، شيئًا
مميزًا فريدًا ، تحب دائمًا إنشاء أشياء جديدة في
معظم الأوقات التي
أحلم فيها بالطبق وفي اليوم التالي
لمحاولة إدراك أنه وضع سيفك
طهي الطبق هو حياتي ،
لذا فهو ليس شغفًا باللحوم ، لذا
فهو هاجس لديه نهج شجاع
للغاية ، ولديه نهج فريد للغاية
يحب أن يجمع بين الأذواق المختلفة
مثلما تذهب إلى هناك وتعتقد في كل
مرة حسنًا لم أكن أتوقع  هذا مثل الحلوى
مع الأسماك والمخللات
وكل ما تقوله مقدمًا
لا لن ينجح
فهو يعرف ما يريد ، لذا فهو
يسير بطريقته الخاصة.
النكهة ويريد دمج هذا
وخياله ، كل طبق لدينا هو من
ذاكرة الطفولة أو أنه
يسير في الغابة ذات يوم
ينظر إلى شيء ما ويفكر جيدًا ، أريد
أن أضع هذا في قائمتنا ماذا يمكنني أن أفعل
[موسيقى  ]
الآن نحن لسنا و  نحن من بودابست في
الريف ، نبحث عن بعض
ثمر الورد لصحراويتي الجديدة ، إنه
مزيج من وردة القلب الثابت
وهو دم
أنا حقًا أحب دم الخنزير لأنني
من ترانسيلفانيا نأكل الكثير من
الدم ، تعرف قلعة دراكولا
ليس قوياً في مسقط رأسي ، لذا فإن نهجه
لا يتمثل في إعادة إنشاء المطبخ المجري من
خلال التحديث وجعله أكثر
حداثة
وتجديدًا ، ولكن للقول حسنًا ، لدينا
مكونات DeSantis في هذه المنطقة ، أريد
إنشاء شيء خاص جدًا
وفريد جدًا وفقًا لوجهي  ذوق
وهذا كان نوعًا من كل المجتمعات كانت
فلسفتي في Ola في الحياة ،
عليك تجربة كل شيء قاله
[موسيقى]
أنت